I guess the grand illusion is my
favorite movie maybe rules of the game a
certain sort of humanism a sense of
connectedness and the recognition of
human beings basic goodness that I find
really appealing I also think that
wealth may be a little bit of a cliche
Citizen Kane is it is really pretty
towering movie when you look at a guy
was doing a lot of jobs and he's
somebody that I look up to enormously
and he was extraordinarily bright
suggest that you know when I started out
lo those many years ago there was not
the kind of democratization of
Technology in other words it wasn't so
cheap this got by a camera could be able
to cut on your laptop before I was just
trying to be a novelist where anybody
could take a crack at it now it really
is you know trot DIY phil mentioned it
really just comes down to your level
creativity and how successfully execute
and what kinds of ideas you have and so
I would start there I would start making
a little movies and make more of them
make Mormon make more of them and
they'll get better better better better
and all of a sudden you'll find that
you've created for yourself a lot of
experience and maybe even some work that
you're proud of and you can build that
up four years before you find this sort
of take that somewhere I tell someone
else that you want them to give you you
know five hundred thousand dollars for
music videos
I'm living with Matt Damon looks like we
all you need to do is move e YT which is
the authority of ye builder who's this
criminal in Boston escaped to California
ultimately that I would probably direct
that he was torrent there a couple of
things in the works oh yeah we have a
company together at more brothers and
part of our mandate is to find something
to do together
my wife would like us to move back to
West Virginia maybe I don't know that
sir she's from actually she she's pretty
happy here um I am NOT interested in
politics I find that to be a little bit
sort of I don't know there's this quote
about from john f kennedy said every
mother wants a sundae well to be
President but they don't want to be a
politician in the process I think
there's some truth about that the ideas
are very noble the practical reality of
doing it is loosely
you